McDavid Newen Hopkins and Hyman your starting
forward line for Edmonton Matthews Marner with
pontis Holberg and a hand off to Marner from
Matthews already back to Matthews and he scores
27 seconds in Toronto has the lead Matthews his
League leading 34th possession in the neutral zone
looked like was in a good position that pick
off by Brody though sends this the other way
and just an aggressive for check Matthews the
little button hook and little drop pass gets
himself to a position and once this Puck is on
his stick he just releases it so quickly it was
a hard pass across by Marner it has to be to get
through everybody but also to give Matthews that
much of a chance with an open net but the puck
trickles free and David Camp will clear ahead
to Noah Gregor and now the leagues have another
look it's Riley shooting and a kick save made by
steuart Skinner Di and looking to go to work
McDavid and Newen Hopkins hover close by it's
McDavid wrap around and a save made Martin Jones
the puck still loose and eventually snatched away
by McDavid Toronto still can't get a touch though
here's Zack Holmes stepping in to the net McDavid
St the save made Martin Jones best of the night
that he draws and then a beautiful little backhand
pass by atle to trade that CH reverse to him
by by CI yard cro and up the left hand side
lilr knows he's going to take a pop Brown gets it
back from toight point black B Jones big save the
third period and Toronto's lost to Colorado on
Saturday here's Hyman breaking three Den Martin
Jones with the left skate hman again checked by
Riley Ean Hopkins Riley trying to Lodge that puck
against the kick plate that's the yellow strip
beneath the Dasher board dug out left eventually
for homberg and now Marner comes over the line
surveys homberg going to get a redirect tipped
home a goal the other day against the Tor to Steel
by Matthews load stitches what what skner denying
home flashing leather and the chant of Stew
goes up at Rogers Dreadful giveaway by McCain
stepping in is Zack Hyman The Cave stands him
up heavy Collision sof chip save by Martin Jones
right there with the left pad beautiful turnover
created by Matthews he spins has an opportunity
I don't like the play to reverse pivot back
in your own Zone not against Edmonton's for
checking pressure D on a snap shot sa Jones
there he covers the rebound against of Vander
Kane the case for Seattle here's a turnover
KNE Lander break away R shot off the crossbar
Skinner got a piece to knock it off the bar
one point ahead of Detroit and Tampa Bay
things have tightened up with the lead's recent
five six and two slump Nan another shot sounded
like it hit the post to tie it up with a sharp
angle shot Twisted away and now C is in breaks
stopped by Skinner rebound no they're going
to wave it off couple times point blank in
the first period Barner will snap it around
Austin Matthews will give it up Marner back
to Matthews pass out of his reach settled by
Riley Mitch Marner in front pinballed around
quick shot score two nothing Toronto scooped up
and buried by Riley this one pinballed around
first before Riley was able to find it but he
comes down from the Blue Line good activation
by him it was Marner the Ford all the way
up at the Blue Line and they get a bounce
and they've been buzzing shift after shift in
the offensive zone Mar will come up take this
pass from Ry you're going to watch him kind of
fight through the check and get himself to the
spot that he elevates in tight after it bounces
around hits es skate little chop pass almost a
a mus shot by Matthews that goes right to Riley
and he finds it and elevates right there so you
can see Skinner reacting to the attempted shot
by Matthews and he got the Feeling Lou that it
was going to take something similar for get one
by Skinner here's hi and putting it upstairs and
Edon has the yes sir career year for Zack hman
him he's on Pace to score 50 goals and they're
taking a real good look at this whether or not
this was offside this is very similar so what we
saw in Detroit where it came out of the Zone
then bounced back in now Edmonton thinks it
might have been off of a lead player which keeps
it on side but they are taking a long hard look
and challenges this is going to most likely be
offside coach's challenge brought to you by spec
Savers reviewing the play was assing the play was
offside that's we have no goal no goal quality
I care and eyewear should be affordable for all
should have gone to spec aers Louis you were on
this one from the GetGo battling for the rebound
to marus against drle digs it out for McDavid and
he breaks free with theander Kane over the line
hits the trailer at back to Bard on to dry CLE
back seal broken Drive ctle a
goal is seventh of the last nine is 21st of the
year and it's 2 on anybody's heading over to the
least bench here but here it is right there
that little movement on the line as it was
on the entry but this is just nice passing
here by Evanson it's Bard with a nice play
back Patience by EOL and then the backand by
dry CLE throws it through he gets a bounce
doy looking for kniv Off the Mark McLoud makes a
move through domy dishing off to Yanmar make the
drive McLoud in front scor gate tied there's
the death goal Derek Ryan has The Equalizer
brand new game to make this all happen here's
the block right there it's Dolby that's trying
to use him as a screen he blocks it one there's
a second one that's denied sent to the corner
and then Ryan McLoud goes to work the skating
through the neutral zone finds his way in and
it's the Poise on the fake shot right here
by Yan mark down to McLoud and then he finds
Ryan in the slot the competitiveness on display
both sides McDavid wrestled down by Riley Crow
screaming for interference CC shot redirected
one rebound the cloud waiting shooting St
the goahead goal Ryan thecloud 305 to play
this place is erupted now Jones did go down
and they're going to take another look at this for
sure Sheldon Keith the coaching staff wondering
if there was goalie interference a follow-up
shift Quick Change gets dry CID of McLoud on
the ice McDavid stays look at this work along
the wall I mean you want to talk about playoff
hockey Midway through the season these two teams
have absolutely battled and then eventually we
talked about these shots with eyes all the
way through great recovery by the cloud he
walks out and finds the back of this is going
to count I mean I don't think there's enough
there by fogal as he's right there on the edge
MC not a chance sorry McDavid I thought that
was fogal beautiful shot by McLoud finds
the back of the net and down two nothing
Everton is clawed back and found the lead and
what an effort by Conor McDavid on this shift
he was out there for that long shift H in
the offensive zone this those guys got a t
rebound to Marner minute 40 to play KNE Lander
across Marner and that was snatched away shot
toward the empty net skittering tumbling
and into the back of the net for an empty
n how's that for touch Evan Bard 4 two
Oilers this has been a little bit of a problem for
Evon put Pucks in open net and he just stops this
Puck and says you know what give it a try a lot
of time on the clock you're under some pressure
he's just trying to put this down but he puts it
directly on the net from the depths of 30th Place
in the National Hockey League to a team that
refuses to let this streak die for tues your
final